[Música]
esto puede parecer una pila de números
bien ordenados pero en realidad es un
tesoro matemático
los matemáticos indios La llamaron
escalera del monte meru en Irán es el
Triángulo de cayam y en China es el
Triángulo yangüe para gran parte del
mundo occidental se le conoce como el
Triángulo de Pascal por el matemático
francés Blas Pascal lo que parece
Injusto es que él llegó claramente tarde
a la fiesta pero todavía tenía mucho que
aportar Qué es lo que tiene que ha
intrigado a los matemáticos de todo el
mundo
en resumen está lleno de patrones y
secretos
en primer lugar está el patrón que lo
genera
comienza con uno e imagina cero
invisibles a cada lado del mismo suma
los pares para generar la siguiente fila
Ahora haz esto una y otra vez sigue
adelante y terminarás con algo como esto
Aunque en realidad el Triángulo de
Pascal continúa infinitamente cada fila
corresponde a los coeficientes de un
desarrollo binomial de la forma x + y
elevado a la n donde n es el número de
la fila empezando a contar desde cero
Así que si haces a n igual a 2 y lo
expandes te da x elevado a la 2 + 2xy +
y elevado a la 2 los coeficientes o
números delante de las variables son los
mismos que los números en la fila del
Triángulo de Pascal
verás Lo mismo con n igual a 3 que se
expande a esto el Triángulo es una
manera rápida y fácil de consultar todos
estos coeficientes Pero hay mucho más
por ejemplo suma los números en cada
fila y obtendrás sucesivas potencias de
o en una fila trata cada número como
parte de una expansión decimal En otras
palabras la fila 2 es uno por uno más
dos por diez más uno por 100 obtendrás
121 que es 11 elevado a la 2
Y echa un vistazo a lo que sucede cuando
haces lo mismo a la fila 6 suma un
millón 771.561
que es 11 elevado a la 6 y así
sucesivamente
también hay aplicaciones geométricas
Mira las diagonales las dos primeras
poco interesantes todos uno y luego los
enteros positivos también conocidos Como
números naturales pero los números en la
siguiente diagonal son llamados los
números triangulares porque al tomar
muchos puntos puedes apilarlos en
triángulos equiláteros la siguiente
diagonal tiene los números tetraédricos
porque del mismo modo puedes apilar
muchas esferas en tetraedros
o qué tal esto sombreado en todos los
números impares no parece mucho con el
Triángulo pequeño pero si agregas miles
de filas obtienes Un fractal conocido
como triángulo de sierpinski este
triángulo no es solo un trabajo de arte
matemático también es muy útil
Especialmente cuando se trata de
probabilidad y cálculos en El dominio de
la combinatoria
digamos que quieres tener cinco hijos y
te gustaría saber la probabilidad de
tener tu familia de ensueño de tres
niñas y dos niños en la expansión
binomial corresponde a chica más chico a
la quinta potencia fijémonos en la fila
5 donde el primer número corresponde a
cinco chicas y el último corresponde a
cinco chicos el tercer número es lo que
estamos buscando 10 de la suma de todas
las posibilidades en la fila de modo 10
sobre 32 o 31,25 por ciento
o si estás escogiendo al azar un equipo
de baloncesto de cinco jugadores de un
grupo de 12 amigos Cuántos posibles
grupos de cinco hay en términos
combinatorios este problema se expresa
como de 12 elegir cinco y podría
calcularse con esta fórmula o podrías
mirar el sexto elemento de la fila 12 en
el Triángulo Y obtener tu respuesta los
patrones en el Triángulo de Pascal son
un testimonio del elegante entretejido
de las Matemáticas
Y todavía está revelando secretos
frescos a hoy por ejemplo se descubrió
recientemente una manera de ampliarlo a
este tipo de polinomios
Qué podemos encontrar a continuación
bueno Eso depende de ti
puede encontrar matemáticas en algunos
lugares muy inesperados tomemos por
ejemplo la noche estrellada de Van Gogh
esta pintura en realidad representa uno
de los misterios más antiguos de las
Matemáticas sabe cuál es descúralo con
este video